LW e on entropic distributions so thank
you Nico thanks a lot yeah this talk to
them give here is based upon joint work
with Zika and okay and what's this talk
gonna be about well I'm gonna talk about
an aspect of leakage resilient
cryptography where we consider a setting
where the secret key of some scheme was
actually accidentally chosen from from
some imperfect distribution or
additional site information about a the
secret key was leaked and specifically
in this talk I want to study this
leakage problem on an assumption level
so we don't want to open up all possible
schemes and try to make them robust but
try to make the underlying assumption
under these schemes already robust okay
and my talk is gonna proceed along the
following lines so first I'm gonna talk
about lwe and entropic lwe or also
called
ugly with weak secrets next I'm gonna
tell you what was known so far about the
hardness of entropic lwe under what
parameters and what underlying
assumptions could be proved that
entropic lwe is hard then I'm gonna show
you a new approach to show hardness of
this problem and finally I'm gonna
provide some lower bounds if if there is
time so in this talk or actually in this
whole sphere in this field there's a
typically a lot of parameters floating
around but I'm gonna try to keep the
parameter madness to a minimum by
omitting certain details
okay let's quickly recap
you're learning with errors problem
defined by in reggae or five so what's
the learning with errors problem we
we're gonna be given a matrix a and a
vector si plus E which is a vector in
the row span noise with this term e and
given these two things our goal is to
find s so this is a what's called a
decoding problem in information theory
here the matrix a will be chosen
uniformly from Z Q to the N times n
where n like this n is the number of
rows and M is number of columns our
secret s will be chosen uniformly random
in Z Q to the N the error term comes
from some short distribution Chi and I
can also state that given that the
number of samples M is large enough or
roughly order of n log Q then the secret
s is uniquely defined by a and si plus e
so it's fair to to ask that an adversary
breaks LW you should just find any s
that has this form but a unique s and
this one will comment maybe this error
distribute this error distribution Chi
can either be a discrete or a continuous
distribution
typically continuous distributions in
our context will be easier to analyze so
that was the search version the decision
of version looks fairly similar the
adversary is either given such a sample
as before and a si plus E or a and a
uniform a uniformly random
after you left side as as before in the
right side we replaced this sample by a
uniformly random vector now a very
appealing aspect about the lwe problem
is that it has a worst-case hardness
guarantee in particular we can if the
error distribution Chi is a Gaussian
discrete or continuous we can show that
this problem is as hard as certain
worst-case lattice problems in
particular we know a quantum reduction
to SIV P I think it's weaker I felt at
last week and a classical reduction to
the gap SVP problem now a certain an
important thing here is the so called
modulus noise ratio alpha which is just
taken this Sigma this Gaussian parameter
and looking at the fraction Q divided by
Sigma this fraction controls the
approximation factor of the worst-case
lattice problem
which these reductions related to okay
um also quickly we can what can we do
with lwe well very first work as shown
we can do public key encryption we can
do multi-party computation of Lydia's
transfer we can do fully homomorphic
encryption in fact LW yi or variants
thereof are essentially the only
standard assumptions or proper
assumptions under which we know fhe a de
for all circuits again only under lwe
and very recently non interactive zero
knowledge so lwe gives us essentially
the a full house of what we want to do
in crypto okay I
told you in the beginning I wanna look
at leakage resilience on an assumption
level and why is that so well for if you
look at many of these constructions from
lwe turns out that the lwe secret s
actually constitutes the secret key so
once we have a leakage resilient version
of LW e we can generically add leakage
resilience to many of these schemes I
think for instance Reagan encryption
where the secret s is in fact the secret
key and why else is interesting well in
Tuesday's session Amit has told you or
explained how a version of lwe with very
strong leakage it can be used to build
io what I'm gonna show you will not
solve this problem but at least Mitchell
has a similar flavor so maybe this can
serve as a different motivation to study
these kinds of problems and finally one
might argue
given the current importance of LW to
studying this problem studying aspects
of this problem and if they retain their
security is a self-supporting though an
income question you know the the leakage
resilience that the dam each needed is a
different notion from what you get I
don't know I don't know really those a
leakage on the secret however this
leakage function
understand this is really just for
motivation why studying this problem is
interesting right yeah I didn't claim
and I would not claim that this really
connects to what's happening in in these
works but again maybe maybe someone will
see a connection
these these techniques right
okay good so let's quickly look at what
we define and tropic lwe so in standard
lwe we chose this this secret s
uniformly random in Z Q to the N and I'm
just gonna draw this it's smoothly a
uniform from the entire space so an
entropic lwe we choose the secret
instead from am in entropy distribution
s right here I've drawn this as a flat
distribution for for flat distributions
you can the main entropy essentially
corresponds to the size or it's just the
log of the size and typically flattest
rebuke and roll something for flat
distributions you can show it for any
minion to be distribution so think of a
minion to be distribution something like
this I'm not gonna provide you with the
proper definition but the important
point is that now the secret S is not
just one fixed distribution but can come
from a actually a large class of
distributions right in
in this example think of if we just
require a certain entropy think of all
distributions or all sets here that have
a certain size right so in fact it's may
be advantageous to think of the
distribution to be chosen an adversary
right when you have an eligible Yui
adversary you think of it as if this
adversary is to to choose his favourite
distribution from the set on which he
wants to
break the problem sorry so when you say
adversarially chosen I start thinking
maybe it needs to be efficiently
computable or efficiently sample or
something really no no for I mean this
they I mean in the end I'm probably
gonna talk a bit about this there might
be interesting extensions but in this
word know it can be I mean an arbitrary
distribution no need for efficient
sample ability okay and of course we can
do the same with the decisional version
we're now also the secret S comes from a
mean entropy distribution s so what have
we known so far about the hardness of
entropic lwe this problem was actually
introduced by GK PV 2010 and they showed
that if you start off with a super
polynomial modulus to noise ratio then
it is a reduction from standard lwe to
entropic lwe given i'm that's an
important restriction given that the
secret is supported on short vectors in
their case actually on binary vectors so
they need to assume that this entropic
secret is binary now a different work be
ltrs 2013 filled hardness of lwe with
binary secrets but not entropy secrets
and a nice aspect about that work was
that it actually preserved the modulus
to most ratio and there were some more a
more refined argument of the GKP v10
argument in a kpw 13 where the modulus
to noise ratio the great son polynomial
ii in the number of samples M number of
M sorry but this was also limited to
short secret
laughter now to see how we can improve
on this I'm first on a recap the
approach of GKP v10 what I'm gonna call
the loss in this technique so the the
idea here is essentially the following
you take the lwd matrix a and replace it
with a pseudo-random matrix which
actually has unusually many short
vectors
you wouldn't I mean basically you
wouldn't expect any short vector in the
span of a uniform a row span of a
uniform you write a matrix a but now
we're kind of planting many short
vectors actually in its row span and
then we can use that this lwe function
sa plus e in fact loses information
about s hence losses approach so let's
see how how these matrices look so
that's a standard LD matrix I'm drawing
here and this is a Samba that's used in
G K P v10 is of the form B times C where
B is a very lean matrix C a very long
matrix and let's give these things and
in fact this matrix F that we add on top
is a short matrix in fact we choose it
from component wise discrete Gaussian
distribution and so if one thing to
observe here is that the left part this
BC part has very low rank
all right so Abby is an no sorry okay I
so
this B is an end times K matrix and here
we have a K times M matrix and the rank
of this matrix B times C is K so it's a
highly ranked efficient matrix and if we
left away this or if you omit it as
matrix F it would be obvious that that
multiplying anything with B times C
loses information but of course that
would be a rank deficient matrix and
that's easily distinguishable from a
uniformly random matrix and now the nice
thing is that under standard lwe we can
show that these two assembles are
indistinguishable I mean if you
basically think of see as an lwe matrix
and B well just take a single single row
of B also just a single row of F then
you just have a single decision lwe
instance and doing this for many rolls
follows by a simple hybrid argument okay
now let's see how we can use such a
Samba to to prove lostness sorry to
prove heart as an entropic lwe well
let's let's let's start with a standard
lwe sample where the secret S comes from
a minute EP distribution supported on
binary vectors okay so first of course
we're replacing a by by a matrix of this
form BC + F and now we're just gonna
rewrite things a little so we're just
gonna distribute s into this sum and
then we have s pc + s f+ e now I said F
is a matrix with short rows or with
short Specter of small spectral norms
s is a binary that
so we can already argue that this term
here is small and that's something we're
gonna use now to argue that essentially
s f+ e is statistically close to an e
prime which has the same distribution as
E and how do we do that well that's a
technique commonly commonly known as
drowning given a given that we have just
a very small offsets think of this as SF
then the statistical distance between
sfrplus
E and this e prime is negligible but
still given that the gaussian parameter
of this error term e is sufficiently
large and that's where this requirement
for having a super polynomial modulus to
noise ratio comes from in their word
okay the the remaining steps are kind of
easy so now we got rid of this
additional dependence on our secret s
and now we have this the only place
where s occurs is this term SP and now
we can argue via the left over half
lemma that since B is chosen uniformly
random and as given that s has
sufficiently mean entropy s times B is
statistically close to a uniformly
random T in the way T is in Z Q to the
to the K the rest then follows by well
looking at this we have TC plus yi
that's again n plus e prime that's again
just an lwe sample so we can replace
this with a uniformly random vector U
and finally we can reverse this first
step that we did and replace BC plus f
again
by a uniformly random matrix a ok that
was essentially the argument of GKP v10
and if we look at what's going on there
then
well this rule fundamentally relies on
the fact that the secret s is short or
and it's supported on short vectors
otherwise we couldn't do this drowning
step if s was arbitrary zq vector then
there was there would be no hope and
showing that s f+ e and e prime are
statistically close all right otherwise
we cannot drown this term well yeah what
i said already the modulus to noise
ratio deviates drastically here and we
need to start with a super polynomial
modulus to noise ratio to begin with
while well after all we would try to do
that with poly modulus to noise ratio
and of course a natural question that
comes off this is is this requirement of
s somehow inherent or rather a
limitation of their proof technique as
you might guess it's the letter now I'm
gonna introduce a new technique that we
call gentle flooding at the source which
will allow us to prove hardness of
entropic lwe for more general okay so in
a nutshell our approach will on a very
high level be kind of the same as GKP
v10 but it has an additional twist so in
particular we will also rely on the LOS
eNOS technique or approach but what's
going to be different is that instead of
analyzing how some residual term that
depends on the secret interferes with
the noise term we we actually look what
happens in part of the
noise leaks into the secret or what
effects the noise has on the secret
directly and to do this we introduce a
new quantity we call the noise losses of
the secret s okay so let's start with
that
what's noise loss eNOS so first off fix
a distribution s of Secrets support it
on Z Q to the N and that s P distributed
according to s and E be a Gaussian with
parameters Sigma now we define
noiselessness to be just the average
conditional min entropy of the secret s
given s plus e in a way you you can
think of this as as taking a secret s
and passing it through a Gaussian
channel however modulo Q typically an
information theory thousand channels are
not much long hue this one is modulo Q
and trying to see how much information
about FS there still is left and that
sort of gives us the alternative way of
defining this just via a maximum
likelihood decoder right so think of
this noise lostness essentially as the
log of the success probability of a best
possible decoder that's given S Plus E
and has to recover s how how can you
think of such a bad as possible decoder
let's say the distribution s is
supported on these four points right we
we add errors and what does what does
the best possible decoder do it
basically decides for the Voronoi cell
so if if let's say my s
he is here then the best possible
decoder is gonna decide for this point
here and yeah this quantity measures the
amount of information lost of or about s
after passing it through a Gaussian
channel and one way to look at this is
to ask really if we think of this minute
to the P distribution s as an error
correcting code we ask how bad is it how
much information does it lose so in
order to use this I'm gonna rely on some
some nice property of Gaussian
distributions namely then I can
decompose them so kind of a well known
fact about continuous gaussians is that
if I take two continuous and independent
gaussians and computer some even if
they're multivariate then it's again a
Gaussian where if they independent
basically the what we do is adding the
covariance matrices right to get the
resulting Gaussian now again here we can
kind of reverse this perspective and say
okay we have a Gaussian now we want to
express it as the sum of two independent
gaussians particular what I want to do
is for a given matrix F I wanna
decompose a Gaussian with parameter
Sigma into something of the form e 1
times F plus e 2 where e 1 is a
spherical Gaussian with parameter Sigma
1 and E 2 is another Gaussian not
necessarily spherical with some other
covariance matrix covariance matrix so
quickly why is this possible well if one
is a spherical Gaussian and our matrix F
has let's say short end
then e 1f in fact is also a Gaussian in
the span of F whether with the
covariance matrix that of course depends
on F but we can show that if this
Gaussian parameter Sigma of e is greater
than the spectral norm of f times Sigma
one then such a such a such a
decomposition actually exists and so
what's the spectral norm of an F if we
chose F from a discrete Gaussian
distribution well if it comes from a
discrete Gaussian with parameter gamma
we will be able to bound the spectral
norm or the largest singular value of F
by something all of gamma times square
root M where m was the number of columns
in this matrix so we kind of have a have
about it doesn't doesn't matter what
what it precisely is well it will affect
the parameters in the end but that's not
a big issue now and so what with these
tools with this notion of noiselessness
and the ability to decompose gaussians
let's see how we can use this to show
hardness of entropic lwe so let's let's
assume that our secret S comes from a
entropic distribution with good noise
loss in us and the first thing again
that I'm gonna do as before is I'm gonna
replace a by a such a yeah by this Osama
be c plus F where again B and C were
this PC part is very low rank and F is
uniform FF is a calcium of parameter now
it's gamma so again I can rewrite that
pulling out the s s but instead of now
trying to argue that somehow drowns this
SF I'm gonna decompose my e into
a 1 F + e2 and we've just seen something
like this is possible now we regroup
things and all of a sudden we have this
term s + e 1 and wait we did it when did
I use that well F is short well I use it
in this step in order to argue that I
have this kind of decomposition and it
can be composed e into e 1 F + 2 - I
need to use that the largest singular
value of F is small okay Niko and a
question for both ik so when you do the
decomposition is sort of important that
Esther than the pound F otherwise your
first step will break right you know
push step you know make sure that Esther
the deeper X yes yes so uh this is I
mean you might call this a non adaptive
version of an entropic LW yeah I don't
know if anyone ever defined an adaptive
version where the the secret depends on
the matrix AE right we wouldn't allow it
to depend on F directly because we just
do that in the hybrid step the weight
depends on a UH that's the woodwork I I
don't think this this would work but in
belief sir
go ahead maybe note you know so so if
you know so if the secret depends on the
matrix a that you cannot prove anything
in any case right you know so yeah yeah
I'm a was does your decomposition depend
on Earth in your decomposition lemma for
decomposing Gaussian that they only need
to know the distribution for F or does
it need to know itself in order to
decompose it right they started to write
down what the distributions of e 1 and E
2 are
you need to give me an F so what we
actually do in the prove is we fix F
right and that's that F is fixed and
we're not going to use anymore that F
comes from a distribution and we just
look at a fix point think of f as fixed
and I mean but the only property that we
need of it is that it has a small
spectrum moment okay okay thanks okay
why why does it break when s depends
when the distribution of s depends on a
I can still replace a would be c plus F
right and the decomposition is in the
composition of it only depends on F yeah
that's right yeah I mean it doesn't
break
maybe you should we discuss later
anyway the high-order bit i guess okay
cool thanks okay so let's quickly look
from here how we can prove hardness of
the search version when we're down here
basically uh let's go full power and say
okay from at that point I'll make my
adversary unbounded he has full power so
now I'm just gonna analyze is the min
entropy of s given given these two
things easy plus F and and that thing
and that can kind of we rewrite this as
mean entropy of a of s just given well
this term up here and and and and this
thing here and you can see everything
else kind of doesn't really depend on on
s and think of all matrices floating
around here as fixed for now so I need
to look at this demand and entropy so
now I'm just gonna throw some generic
thing at this namely am in entropy chain
rule to get rid of this SP ax
I mean I can lower bound
actually this is lower bounty
what I'm losing there by the size of the
domain from which this SP comes and this
has I mean that bit length K times a lot
of Q a a very standard thing I'm not
gonna get into that and the first thing
now is actually just my noise loss in us
so uh what I'm gonna get is that if my
noise loss eNOS is of this s is a little
bit bigger than this K lot Q then this
problem will be hard because even an
almighty a powerful adversary will not
be able to find the correct s anymore
recall I said at the beginning that
without loss of generality I can require
him to find the right one now there's
this this argument here can be improved
in both s and D are short and is
actually I mean in terms of s we need to
have a short distribution again but B
can be made short by relying on the
Hermit form of then we can actually make
this term independent of loci but I'm
not gonna get into that so then there
was a showing hardness for the for the
searched version what if we want to show
directly hardness of the decisional
version well in this case will again
meet that this distribution s is
extractable by ax LH l this is for
instance the case if the the modulus hue
is a prime what what can we do then and
then we can actually add then we can
actually state that since we know that
average conditional min entropy of FF s
given s plus e1 is still big well if
that part is big enough we can again
apply the left over 1/2 lemma and
replace this s
we buy something uniformly random and
the rest of the argument now then is
exactly the same as in GK PV okay so
let's quickly look at the kind of
parameters that we need so first we need
to assume that we have L let's assume we
have LW u with parameter Sigma and then
this gives us hardness of entropic lwe
with parameter Sigma 1 times Sigma times
square root M essentially this this
sigma x square root m comes from this
fact that is well from this interference
with this matrix F but what this means
is that the modulus to noise ratio to
yeats by a factor Sigma 1 times square
root of M so I haven't told you yet how
much min entropy we need from these
distributions to begin with but know how
much more time do I have like 5 minutes
like let's call it eight minutes eight
minutes thanks okay good so let's
quickly see how or glossed over how we
can compute the noise loss in us so in
the first case let's say we have a
general min entropy distribution on Z Q
to the N so this is a distribution about
which we really don't know anything
except that it has sufficiently high
minute repeater so that essentially it's
support is somewhat sufficiently dense
in Z Q to the N in that case if we add
noise if it's dense enough and basically
if you think of this this distribution
as an as a code it will be over calling
and then will actually be
of overlap between these errors fears so
in that case we'll be able to compute
the voice loss in us as a min entropy of
s minus n times log Q divided by Sigma
where this well lock you divided by
Sigma basically tells us how dense how
dense we we can pack these balls in the
in the ambient space for instance if you
think about Sigma yeah I think of a
quick example even if H of s has full
minute repear
if it's like n log Q then if Sigma is
too small if we're just adding tiny
errors then essentially there's not a
lot of noise loss units left so in the
end what will be the case here is that
either we need to start with a
distribution which has almost full
entropy to begin with or Sigma is very
big right because if you make Sigma
something like almost as big as Q then
this extra this last year or this defect
and entropy will in fact be very small
okay that's the case for general
distributions now we do get something
better for short distributions or ball
bounded distributions when they are all
clustered together in a small sphere and
it doesn't need to be centered around
zero or anything then you can tell the
overlap right the overlap thing think of
the over the more overlap you have the
better the more noise lostness if you
think about
most lost in us in terms of this maximum
likelihood decoder so in the bounded
setting you you will have much more
overlap in fact we will be able to get
much better parameters so there's
there's no logarithm here but I mean you
can see that this second term here
doesn't depend on Q anymore at all so
you just have to make Sigma large enough
and it's essentially all the min entropy
of of s is retained okay so so much for
that and the main our main result says
something along the following lines
assuming that LW Yi of dimension K
modulus Q and parameter gamma is hard
then for general non short minutes
entropy distributions we get that
entropic LW yi with distribution SN m
and n NQ m and Sigma is hard
given that the entropy of s is at least
K times la Q and K remember comes from
the underlying lwe problem plus well n
times lock u divided by Sigma times some
polynomial thing that depends on M and
the original Gaussian parameter but this
is something that mostly depends on say
here roughly n log Q divided by Sigma
these are the this is the the dominant
term here in can i okay
interns are if we have all bounded
distributions we get something better in
fact we will we will get an entropy
requirement of s that's in fact
independent of the modulus
that's a new aspect that wasn't known
before so so far you needed to have at
least something like K lock you entropy
as up here but given given this analysis
for if you have a ball bounded
distribution you can even work with
entropy that's independent of you so the
last few seconds or minutes myths maybe
talk about lower bounds I'm not gonna go
through all the slides but for the
general case well the the main entropy
of s must be as I said somewhere close
to n log Q or Sigma the noise parameter
of the of your entropic lwe problem must
be really large somewhat somewhat the
same order of Q and this is really not
desirable and the question is can we do
better for general entropic distribution
or is this as good as it gets and if you
give me the freedom to choose myself
modulus then the answer is actually no
than this result is essentially tight
just quickly jump over that what this
says is if I have a composite modulus I
can actually provide a matching attack
which if I go with my entropy a little
bit below this end times lock you but
divided by Sigma then I actually do have
an attack I'm not going to go into into
this here due to lack of time and
further we look at the question well
what what if you forbade me to use a
composite modulus what if zq doesn't
have any any sub structure well we can
still show something namely that
basically
you will not be able to base the
hardness of entropic lwe on any on any
standard assumption via a black box
adverse area and sorry black box
reduction we use the simulated
adversaries framework of wakes I'm gonna
jump right over these slides and go to
the takeaway so what are the conclusions
oh oh but what we found is that standard
lwe with standard lwe or standard
entropic lwe with non short secrets can
tolerate a small amount of leakage or
weak secrets now why is this small well
the smallness has some inherent reasons
either they are matching attacks or a
black box impossibility so in a way what
this suggests and this is my take away
my personal interpretation is that if
you use elderly with short or binary
Secrets
this actually tolerates a much higher
leakage rate but if you kind of do the
math this will come at the cost of
larger public keys roughly by a factor
of law hue and just quickly few open
problems what about if we restrict
ourselves to more specific classes of
distributions or likud functions again
think of these polynomials in omits
assumption
what about leakage that includes the
noise now the techniques that I've shown
they do translate somewhat to learning
with rounding but not really nicely you
can't do anything as nice as this
Gaussian decomposition lemma in the case
of our and some question I think is
interesting does this black box
impossibility extend to the to say
quantum reductions I mean the way it is
now probably not and since quantum
reductions are
are really a staple in Latin script or
might be an interesting thing to ask and
you can you get something better with
prime modulus and quantum reductions and
what about structured versions like
ringing out of you okay but I'm already
over time that's it thanks so I think
we're yeah a bit over time so maybe we
can take questions offline and I guess
howtechs in charge of when we reconvene
huh right hi good sorry we forgot to be
such should we pick up time to reconvene
say to eight minutes oh yeah let's say
let's say like eight minutes so 10:40
Pacific time okay thank you